I can go through this way, I'm sorry.
Okay.
You can pause using the, play and pause using the space bar.
Do I just talk now?
Yeah, yes, you can talk right now.
Okay.
Okay, I remember thinking the start was pretty strong, like my footwork could have been better
and like, oh my gosh, this is going so fast, and like obviously more power, but I thought
it was a pretty strong start, and then for that sequence, I remember trying to go like
focus on the smoothness of my arms and like staying powerful.
Um, yes.
Okay.
This part, I remember just focusing on the sidekick, and I remember I like lost balance
a little bit, especially on this one, I like did not land that, oh.
Okay, this part I was focusing on speed and kind of like tempo, so making sure like the
parts that were supposed to be singular were strong on its own, and then the parts that
were connected.
Um.
Kind of like flowed together well, like this part was like a singular, and I remember thinking
my key-up sounded different.
Um, and then here I was focusing on kind of not turning my foot or making any small moves
before going on to the next sequence, um, and also focusing on over-exerting power,
so like overturning my upper body to get power on that move.
Um, and I also remember thinking like, oh my gosh, like it's ending.
Okay.
This, the punch was not very good.
The first punch could have been more like stable and strong.
Okay, this part, I feel like I could have like held onto that move a little bit more.
Um, yes.
I remember thinking like my front kicks were not bad.
Okay, yeah, like the first punch could have obviously been...
more like strong and like...
I don't know, like more there, like more present.
Okay, yes.
And I remember thinking like I didn't end up where
I started.
Okay.
Ha.
You were annoying.
Okay...
You probably need this, but you can fast forward.
So, as you can see, your pattern is scored based on the number 10.
So, out of 10 is your mark.
As you can see, it's split up into two parts.
We have our accuracy and our presentation of the site.
So, we'll start off with the accuracy first.
So, your accuracy is actually scored from a 4.
So, from the number 4, you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern.
And then, with that one, any mistakes that you make,
if it's a minor mistake, you get minus 0.1.
If it's a major mistake, you get minus 0.3.
So, I'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two.
So, with a minor mistake, it's a very, very small thing.
So, let's say we're doing an out-of-block.
If it's not your shoulder height, maybe it's a little bit lower,
or maybe it's a tiny bit higher, that's a minor mistake, so that's a 0.1.
A major mistake would be, you're supposed to do an out-of-block in the pattern,
but you forget, and you say you do a reach-hand strike instead.
So, that would be a major mistake.
So, with a minor mistake, let's say pattern 1, for example, there's 20 steps.
It's not uncommon.
It's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14, 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns,
sorry, in the 20 steps.
So, the reason for that would be, it needs to be absolutely perfect
to not get a deduction of 0.1.
So, it's not uncommon to say there's 20 steps, and you made, let's say, 15 mistakes.
So, what would that be?
So, we'll leave that there on this side,
and we'll come back, and we'll just calculate the score at the end.
So, a major mistake, say you're supposed to turn to the left,
but you turn to the right, that would be a major mistake.
So, obviously, we do want to try and avoid any of these major mistakes.
So, after we've done our pattern,
that's when we move on to the presentation side.
So, the presentation, as you can see, it's from a score of 6.
This 6 is actually split up into 3 parts.
So, we have 1, 2, 3 here.
So, with this one, for a score of 2 is your power and speed.
Your rhythm is also a score of 2,
and your expression of energy is also scored out of 2 as well.
So, we'll start off with the power and speed.
So, with this one, whether it's your blocks, your kicks, your strikes, your punches,
anything you are going to do, you need to be nice and strong,
and it has to be fast as well.
So, it's one thing to have a very strong punch, or a very fast punch,
but it has to be both strong and fast to get,
high in that category.
So, the next part is your rhythm.
So, the rhythm, when you do start your pattern, there is a rhythm to the pattern.
It's not just really fast all the way through.
It's not slow all the way through.
There's a slow, fast, slow, fast kind of aspect to it as well.
So, you do need to kind of work on a rhythm, and that's also scored out of 2.
The last bit is your expression of energy.
So, what is expression of energy?
So, that's basically how loud you shout,
so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well.
So, say you're doing your pattern really well,
it's really fast and it's strong, your rhythm is really great,
but you're not shouting very loud,
or you can kind of tell, the judges can kind of tell,
oh, you're not really...
confident, you're a little bit nervous,
so that's what we need to kind of improve on as well.
So, I'll just come around to this side.
So, with this one, for color belts and black belts,
it's actually scored a little bit differently.
So, if you're a color belt, you'll actually...
your average, so you did alright,
you did average compared to everyone else,
your score for 1, 2, and 3,
it'll start from a 1.1.
So, if you're less than average in the judges' eyes,
you might go down to, say for your power and speed,
you might get a 1 or even a 0.9.
If you did really great, you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4.
So, each individual category,
you need to obviously get as high as you can.
If you're a black belt,
generally, depending on the competition,
you will be scored from a 1.3.
So, 1.3 would be your average that you start from.
So, say your power and speed was above average,
you might get scored a 1.4 for now.
Say your rhythm was only about average,
it wasn't amazing, it might be just a 1.3,
but let's say you didn't shout very loud,
so your expression of energy, your average was 1.3,
it might go up to, say, let's say 1.0.
So, with this one, we'll comment down to this side.
So, with this one, as I was saying, it's a total of 10.
So, let's see.
So, for presentation, we have 1.7, 1.2.3.
So, you get a 3.7.
Let's say you made 15 mistakes.
So, with this one, obviously, don't be too discouraged
if you do get pretty high in your mistakes.
This is with the judges.
We have three judges usually at the panel,
and each judge, obviously, is very subjective.
So, from their point of view,
you might have made a lot of mistakes,
or you may have made not a lot of mistakes as well.
So, that's why we have the three judges,
and we average it out as well.
Okay.
So, say we did our 15 mistakes, very small mistakes.
So, if they're all minus 0.1, it'd be 1.5.
So, you go 4.0 minus 1.5, which equals 2.5.
So, this would be your accuracy score.
So, with our presentation like before,
we're saying we got a 3.7 here.
So, we add these numbers after the judges are finished scoring.
So, you would get, for this pattern, a 6.2,
which is actually very good.
So, I'll just talk a little bit more now about this number here.
So,
if you're a color belt, if you're a yellow or above,
and you do your patterns, it's not uncommon.
Generally, for a color belt,
the average is generally considered pretty good.
So, anything above that, you can consider yourself pretty good.
If you're a black belt, the average would say,
because we're talking here about the high presentation as an average,
anything from 5 to 6 is actually considered pretty good.
And anything over a 7 is actually considered almost world class.
So, if you get a 7 for any of your patterns,
you generally need to,
you need to pat yourself on the back because you did an amazing job.
So, we just went through our full-tape scoring.
So, just remember, accuracy is a 4.0, presentation is a 6.0, accuracy is a 5.0.
So, with this one, obviously, say I was judge number one,
I will give you a 6.2.
There was another judge on the other side.
Maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than I did.
Maybe this one would be a little bit lower.
It might be a 5 point something.
Another judge on the other side, they scored a little bit higher.
So, we get three numbers and then we average that as well.
So, I hope this helped you guys.
So, make sure you enjoy your full-tape competition.
And any...
We're going to be rating yourself.
This time, you cannot pause the video.
It's like a real judge looking at performance.
So, we're going to practice minor errors, major errors.
You can do this real time.
Okay.
And then, power and speed, coordination of rhythm.
This is right after the performance expression of energy.
Okay.
Okay. So, this one I do like after watching.
This is jewelry you're watching.
When you're ready, you can press.